only a third of Americans think that
President Obama has handled foreign
policy better than his predecessor
George W Bush
hi I'm Zach why similar for reason TV
i'm here with emily ekins the polling
director for Reason Foundation she also
runs the reason roop pull the latest of
which features several questions
regarding the possible US intervention
in Syria Emily thank you very much for
joining us thanks for having me the
Obama administration has been pushing
very hard for intervention in Syria and
it seemed all but inevitable a couple
weeks ago that there probably was going
to be some sort of military intervention
there there seemed to be a sort of
turning point when the British
Parliament actually voted not to
intervene in Syria how are Americans
reacting to this idea of going in
without British support and without UN
support Americans do not think the US
should go it alone but to be clear
Americans do feel that the international
community does have a responsibility to
respond in some way to the reports that
the Assad regime has used chemical
weapons against his people however that
does not mean that Americans favor more
military intervention abroad now for one
Americans don't think that it's in our
national security interest to intervene
they don't think it's going to prevent
the regime from using chemical weapons
in the future and they're worried that
it will lead to more to US troops on the
ground in Syria even if we get involved
just a little bit today for these
reasons three-fourths of Americans
believe it would be unwise for the u.s.
to launch military airstrikes against
Syria without the UN or Great Britain
that being said even with their support
Americans still are hesitant to
intervene abroad after the allegations
regarding Assads chemical weapons use
became public a lot of pundits were
telling us that if we don't intervene
now it's a credibility issue and
therefore hurts America's national
security how are the American people
reacting to this credibility argument
the American people don't buy it in fact
nearly two-thirds say it is not
necessary for us to launch military
airstrikes against Syria in order for us
either to remain credible or to protect
national security pulling up to this
point in regards to foreign policy is
been pretty favorable for Obama but your
poll results showed a rather striking
difference what did you find and how
much do you think that the issue of
Syria has affected the overall
perception of Obama's foreign policy
Syria has hurt people's perception of
the president's handling of foreign
policy in the past the president was
viewed as the non-interventionist
alternative a candidate and a president
who espoused making transparency a
priority for his administration but our
poll shows that Americans are
disappointed in the president in fact
for most of President Obama's presidency
a majority has supported his handling of
foreign policy but as of our poll nearly
six and ten americans disapprove of his
handling of foreign policy and certainly
Syria has played a significant role in
the public's disappointment with the
president even more devastating for the
Obama administration is that only a
third of americans think that President
Obama has handled foreign policy better
than his predecessor George W Bush Emily
Ekins thank you very much for talking to
us the full poll results related to this
topic will be available at reason.com
forward slash poll for reason TV I'm
Zach y smaller